d'autres rassemblements à l'initiative
cette fois ci le président des patriotes
florian philippot le cortège ne devrait
plus tarder à partir de la porte
dauphine estelle vous y êtes
actuellement y at il du monde
[Musique]
et oui amira et il ya du monde on vous
allez le voir sur ces images de à didier
à mulhouse les manifestants sont encore
en train d'arriver ici place du paraguay
sur les lieux du rendez vous donc et à
cette tête de cortège ans qui est en
train de se former voilà ce sont allés à
derniers préparatifs avant le départ du
cortège résistance et c'est le mot
d'ordre un ici pour cette manifestation
à l'initiative du chef de file des
patriotes florian philippot qui
revendique une 43e semaine de
mobilisation de résistance résistance je
le disais pas contre le pass sanitaire
en mesure à qui ne passe toujours pas
parmi ceux à qui sont ici un car ils
considèrent et bien cette mesure comme
est liberticide et puis sachez que c'est
le dernier samedi de mobilisation avant
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants à qui entrera en vigueur le 15
septembre prochain et à certains ici
espère encore faire reculer le
gouvernement sur ce point à l'image de
mode cette étudiante dans le secteur de
la santé que nous avons rencontré jeu
proposera d'écouter ces témoignages
suis en études de santé effectivement
j'ai du mal à me résigner
voilà sur cette vaccination obligatoire
mais même pour toutes les personnes
finalement obligé comme ça voilà on va
dire l'hépatite b l'hépatite b ça a été
obligé obligatoire mais là c'est pas on
va dire que c'est pour ce vaccin là
c'est pas le moment quand c'est de le
rendre obligatoire on veut pas lui
passer le k on veut la liberté après si
chacun faisait des gestes barrières
correctement je pense qu'il aura pas de
problème les fois que le gouvernement
arrête de 2,2 précédemment la population
c'est pas normal j'ai pas le pass je
m'en suis pas servi et je suis très bien
comme ça donc
entre guillemets les restos et les
cinémas on peut s'en passer un certain
temps mais après un moment donné on va
vouloir récupérer notre liberté du côté
de la manifestation le cortège va
prendre la direction de la place du
trocadéro lieu de dispersion où une
scène a été installée à là bas et où des
prises de parole devrait être organisée
merci estelle pour toutes ces précisions
et pions noirs